Mhm, Stefan Michael, zusammenbricht, yeah.
RTO sagt Boo, Rockstar live im Nightliner, schiesse aus dem Car to go mit brandheissen zwei Zeilern, yeah.
Movie-Star sowie De Niro, ich bin Franta, du bist Zero. Yeah, yeah. Ich habe eine ganze Menge verpasst. Ja, ihr habt so unrecht geskippt. Das Intro war fantastisch, Young Urheber ist am Start. Nicht schlecht? Vielen, vielen Dank, mega tolles Intro. Ich merke wieder, ich bin zu langsam für Hip-Hop, ich bin zu langsam für Rap, mein Kopf kommt nicht so schnell mit, bei mir ist es ein reines Fetzenfliegen vorbei, bei mir kommt kaum was an, aber das, was ankommt, finde ich atemberaubend. Du bist der, der bei Eight Mile in der ersten Reihe steht, immer so mit flimmernden Augen. Bitte was? Was, was, was? Ah, okay, weil seine Mutter fett ist, sagt er jetzt Troutan. Ja, und dann ist er wieder zehn Minuten vergangen. Ach und alle, wow, hey, ho, was, hey, hey, verstehe ich nicht. Herzlich willkommen zu einer, ich sag mal, Unplugged-Version des Podcast-Ufos, denn wir wurden beraubt, uns wurde Equipment gestohlen, das heißt, wir sind heute auf halber Sparflamme. Ja, Flon hier hat, also wenn man jetzt sich ein Mikrofon vorstellt, dann sieht man ja häufig, das Mikrofon davor ist ein grosses, schwarzes Etwas, das nennt man Popschutz, das ist dafür da, damit man S und P-Laute ein bisschen schluckt, damit es für euch erträglich in euren Öhrchen klingt.
Also falls ihr euch fragt, warum ihr noch nie ein S oder ein T gehört habt im Podcast.
Jemals.
Im Podkar, dann wisst ihr jetzt.
Nee, im Otkar.
Im Otkar.
Ja, dann liegt es daran, weil der Popschutz funktioniert hat.
Wenn es mal eins durchgerutscht ist, liegt es daran, weil wir die Belegen genommen haben.
So, und jetzt ist ein Eidenringling hier eingebrochen in das Studio und hat sich die wahrscheinlich wertlosesten Gegenstände ausgesucht, um sie zu stehlen. Er hat sich beschlossen, die Mikrofon hier zu lassen und die teuren Hetzes, hat aber dafür beschlossen, die Popstütze zu klauen. Und ja, jetzt gucke ich auf einen Florentin, der da sitzt, der da rumlungert und sich einen Kaffeefilter auf das Mikrofon geschraubt hat. Du, das unterscheidet einen echten guten Podcaster von einem Anfänger, der gute Podcaster weiß. Er macht das nicht. Der hört auf. Der sucht einen Popschutz und macht das oder ohne, weil das ist ja auch nicht dramatisch. Wir haben schon folgenlang Englisch geredet oder auf den Tisch gehauen achtmal. So, da ist es auch immer okay, wenn man eine Folge nicht mit Popschutz aufnimmt. Es ist der moderne MacGyver. MacGyver muss sich auch über wie kann man die neue Staffel du klingst jetzt wahrscheinlich wir hören es denn gerade nicht wir können wir haben nicht die Chance es abzuählen wahrscheinlich hört man nicht gar nicht gerade man hört mich Koffein reingert hat er gerade MacGyver gesagt wir wissen es nicht hat er Geier oder MacGyver gesagt das Problem ist die ganzen Gags werden rausgefiltert durch den Kaffeefilter das ist halt ein bisschen das Problem ja oder halt Koffein warte es bleibt nur Kaff Leute, ich sag mal, jetzt haben wir mal ein bisschen Spaß, der Filter kommt weg, oder?
So, jetzt hört man wirklich das erste Mal. Oh, hier bin ich, herzlich willkommen, hier ist Florentin an Mike. Ach, Florentin. Ja, fand ich eine gute Line aus dem Intro, ich bin Fanta, du bist Zero, finde ich cool. Das hätte ich mir mal aufheben sollen. Selbst du hast vergessen, dass dein ehemaliger Spitzname Fanta war. Ja, du hast dich sehr gefreut über die Le. Ich habe gesagt, mach keine Werbung bitte im Intro schon. Und dann hast du gesagt, aber du bist Fanta. Für mir ein Jahr, das war ja mal der Spitzname, den ich mir selber geben wollte. Ich habe es aber selber nicht geschafft, den mir selber einzureden. Aber vor allem, diese Line ist nicht mal mir eingefahren, derjenige, der sich Fanta für mich selbst ausgedacht hat. Also ich bin ja der Urheber des Namen Fanta für mich selbst. Eigentlich müsste ja so ein Spruch dem Ganzen zugrunde liegen, lag ja nicht mal. Du hast deine ganze Jugend versucht, dass Leute dich Fanta nennen und einmal hat dich jemand Fanta gerufen und du hast nicht reagiert. Da hab ich gesagt, was? Wer? Fanta? Melanie? Oder was? Keiner, einfach, ah shit, ich war's. Ach so shit, bin ich ja. Aber wie gesagt, du bist ja auch der, der beim Hip-Hop-Konzert die Nachbarn antubt und so, sorry, ganz kurz, die Leinen gerade mit den Hoes und den Bitches. Vor zwölf Bars, vor Haupt mit den Hoes und den Beans. Was ist jetzt eine Ho? Ist das so ein Schlauch oder was soll das sein? Ich verstehe die ganzen Referenzen nicht. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich bin da nicht drin in der Musik. Deswegen ist es auch schwer, in Hip-Hop reinzukommen, weil man, dann machen die auch mal Anspielungen auf andere Tracks und so. Was ist denn so das erste Album, also weil, was ist das erste Hip-Hop-Album, was ich hören muss? Schön Blumentopf oder schön damals, schön 1996, München der Innenstadt, Karlsplatz, gute Show einfach. Das ist sauber, Sammy Deluxe, das ist sauber, da sind keine Flies, da sind keine Drops drin, da sind keine Beats, da hast du einfach nur freien Zucker auf der Schallplatte, das ist genau das, was du hast. Dendemann kenne ich. Das ist eine Zeit, die habe ich diese Woche verstanden. Du kennst doch Hey Ja, ne? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, heytert. Und dann sagt er doch, Ladies, I wanna have you on your worst behavior. Lend me some sugar, I am your neighbor. Ich weiss nicht, ob du dich an die Zeit erinnern kannst. War jetzt auch melodisch nicht perfekt dargeboten. Nie verstanden. Er sagt ja, lend me some sugar, I am your neighbor. Und jetzt habe ich es gecheckt, was er damit meint. Lend me some sugar im Sinne von, zeigt mir was Süsses. Er er fordert sich auf zu tanzen und es ist direkt vor dem shake it like a Polaroid picture, wo auch die heutigen Kids sagen, like a what, like a what, like a polo, what do you mean, Polaroid, what is that, obwohl vielleicht wegen den Instagram-Filtern, aber dann wird es noch verwirrender, wenn man an den Instagram-Filter denkt, egal, auf jeden Fall sagt er, shake me like Abu Abu Dhabi-Filter. Und dann sagt er, lend me some sugar, im Sinne von, zeig mir was Süsses, I am your neighbor. Ja, ich verstehe schon, weil man dem Nachbarn, der immer nach Zucker fragt. Dem Nachbarn leiht man Zucker. Ich fand die Zeit immer so random, immer so, I am your neighbor. Was? Das habe ich aber gerade beim ersten Mal schon gedacht. Ja? Dann dachte ich, erklärst du mir jetzt, was der andere bedeutet? Nie, die habe ich mir nicht verstanden. Ich habe nur die, komm rüber und frag mich nach Zucker, die habe ich verstanden. Nee, bei mir war es genau andersrum. Deswegen passen wir so gut zusammen. Ja, vielleicht. Ich vergesse jeden, du vergisst Young und am Ende sind wir zusammen. Aber in der Hand haben wir gar nichts. Haben wir nichts. Bei der Hand stehen wir mit nichts da. Kommen wir nie auf das Thema zu sprechen, weil wir es beide nicht wissen. Vertikutierer wurde sich bei uns immer geliehen. Unser Nachbar hat sich nie den Zucker geliehen, aber immer den Vertikutierer, wo ich bis heute nicht genau weiss, was es ist. Ich glaube, du machst den Boden, ja. Vertikal, oder was? Nee, du, ja. Der Boden ist ja horizontal. Ah, aber so viel zu horizontal. Ja, genau. Beim Einzigen dachten wir uns noch, das geht. Besorgen Sie sich jetzt, den Vertikutierer, und machen Sie alles Horizontale vertikal. Jetzt bei Ihrem Nachbarn. Nee, tatsächlich macht das, glaube ich, so, es vertikutiert den Boden letztlich. Ja, klar. Manchmal denkt man sich, der müsste echt mal wieder vertikutiert werden. Entweder zum Düngen oder es raucht dann so auf. Das sind Verben, Alter, vertikutieren. Und die beiden französischen Austauschstenden, die uns gerade zuhören, denken sich, okay, da schreibe ich mir in meine Vokabel-App. Vertikutieren, das braucht man bestimmt. Und sie lernen es, und sie lernen es immer wieder, und irgendwann haben sie es. Aber Google geht davon aus, man kennt es. Also, ich habe jetzt mal vertikutieren eingegeben, und Google sagt, wann ist die beste Zeit, um den Rasen zu vertikutieren, bei welchem Wetter vertikutieren, vertikotiere ich richtig ja aber dann wird zu viel vertikutieren die fünfte frage ist was ist what the fuck ist vertikutieren okay unter vertikutieren versteht man das anritzen der grasnarbe einer rasenfläche ein sehr schöner deutscher satz für mich also noch mal von so französischen, je m'appelle Stephan. Bonjour. Unter Vertikutieren versteht man das Andritzen der Grasnarbe einer Rasenfläche, um Mulch, altes Schnittgut und Moos zu entfernen und die Belüftung des Bodens zu fördern. Der ursprünglich englische Ausdruck ist aus den Wörtern vertikal und to cut zusammengesetzt.
Vertikatieren, jetzt verstehe ich's.
Vertical cutting.
Ah, schön, und die Babette aus Paris sagt, heute habe ich gelernt, Grasnarbe, Mulch,
Grasnarbe, de vertikutiere de Grasnarbe an Ritzen der Rasenfläche.
Je verticurer, tu verticure, il verticure, nous verticurant. Ja, und so geht's. Wir hatten verticutiert. Tatsächlich lerne ich auch manchmal französische Vokabeln, wo ich mir denke, niemand braucht die. Letztens habe ich in meine Vokabel-App getippt, das deutsche Verb durchfurchen. Silonet heißt das. Und ich habe es gelernt. Oh, klingt total schön, aber. Ich habe es gelernt und werde ich jemals in meinem Leben das Verb durchfurchen, ich durchfurche, du durchfurchst, er, sie, es durchfurcht, wir durchfurchen, also für alle da draußen. Das ist der Austausch, französisch, deutsch. Ehrlich gesagt, können wir mal einen Austausch, einen Podcast-Austausch machen? Können wir mal unser Pendant in Frankreich finden? Ohne Scheiss, weil wir haben damals immer einen Schulaustausch gemacht, wir sind gereist nach, ja, weiß nicht mehr, wo das war, ich war auch nicht im Kurs.
Die Partnerstadt von meiner Heimatstadt Ebersberg ist Isonchon. Das war auch eine grosse Herausforderung, bis man das mal aussprechen konnte. Fängt mit Y an, dann Doppel-S, dann kommt Q, E, U, X und als Kind... Acht X, dann und dieser Strich, den man aus Star Wars Planeten kennt.
Ja, und Ortsschild denkst du dir auch so, vergiss es, Yson-Champ.
Und Montpellier weiß ich nicht mehr.
Auch schön.
Oh, herrlich.
Das hat das Kaff einfach abgerissen Kriminalität, aber Montpellier und die auch aus Cetremont.
Ich möchte in irgendein Dreckskaff in Frankreich fahren, weil da unser Pendant podcastet. Pendant. Pendant podcastet. Du kannst ein bisschen deine Französischen Kenntnisse aufpolieren, durch Früchten kann man sagen, und dann können wir zusammen, das finde ich mega, wenn wir ein bisschen Frankreich und Deutschland wieder ein bisschen nach vorne umsen. Ja, da müssen wir echt zusammenflicken. Tatsächlich, was ich letztens gelernt habe, Franzosen lassen vor dem Ausrufezeichen und dem Fragezeichen noch ein Leerzeichen. Oh, wo kommt das her? Das frage ich mich ganz oft. Das ist normal im Franzischen und ich dachte mir sofort, okay, sofort zwei Weltkriege verstanden, weil das muss bekämpft werden. Das sieht so furchtbar aus, Leerzeichen vor dem Ausrufezeichen und Leerzeichen vor dem Fragezeichen. Manche Leute machen das und ich dachte mir, die sind einfach einfach dumm, stellt sich heraus, sind Franzosen. Ähnlich, die versuchen sich einzuschleichen. Ähnlich schlimm finde ich einen Punkt nach einem Emoji. Emojis funktionieren als Satzzeichen. Nochmal alle zusammen. Emojis funktionieren als Satzzeichen. Ausrufezeichen. Hör auf! Danach kommt kein Ausrufezeichen, kein Punkt, kein Fragezeichen mehr. Okay, verstehe. Okay? Aber kann man Komma machen? Ich hab dich lieb, Herz, Komma. Nein, die gehören nicht in den Satz, es sei denn, du machst so ein, ich fahre mit dem zu dir. Was für dich auch eine Herausforderung der modernen Welt ist, ist die Genitivbildung bei Ad-Handles auf Twitter. Ich war zu Gast in Stefans Podcast. Ad-Stefan. Esithios. Esteban Tithios, du kannst das S nicht dranhängen, sonst wäre es ein anderes Adhandle. Ist es dein Leerzeichen S? Ich spiege es nicht und nehme es als Brand. So wie die Ärzte. Genau. Wir waren im Podcast von die Ärzte. Ja. Du hast von. Wir. Wir waren in die Ärzte's Podcast. Die Ärzte Podcast. Ich war im die Ärzte Podcast. Nee. Ja, ist schon schwierig. Aber nochmal, wenn ihr da, wenn ihr draußen Franzosen seid vielleicht sogar oder Franzosen kennt, die einen Podcast haben, der wie wir ist, nur auf Französisch. Was heißt denn das Podcast UFO auf Französisch? Le Podcast UFO. UFO. UFO. Le Podcast UFO. Die würde ich gerne kennenlernen, deren Stéphane und Florenton. Florenton. Die möchte ich gerne ... Ja, aber wie stellst du dir das vor? Dann machen die mal eine Folge hier, wir machen ... Dauchen wir in deren Podcast auf und verstehen kein Wort und sie bei uns verstehen auch kein Wort. Wir laden die ein, reden auf Englisch mit denen, auf Französisch du ein bisschen, Bruchschiff, Bruch, Bruch, Bruch, Bruch, Bruch, Bruchstückhaft.
Bruchstück auf Schifffahrt und Schiffbruch auf Bruchstück.
Und dann sind wir bei denen eingeladen und machen das gleiche, einfach so ein bisschen
meinen Diskurs anzustacheln.
Wir verstehen kein Wort.
Du lernst seit acht Jahren Sprache.
Ja, dann kann ich, wenn die nicht zufällig von Durchfurchen reden und irgendwelche Begriffe aus dem 18. Jahrhundert von Napoleon, dann habe ich keine Ahnung, wovon die reden. Die können ja auch Englisch, wenn man eines von Frassosen weiss, dass sie perfekt Englisch sprechen. Ja, die lieben das. Deswegen würde ich gerne sagen, machen wir das. Gute Idee. Wir haben ja bei guter Arbeit einen Sketch-Austausch mit Finnland gemacht. Da haben wir tatsächlich eine finnische Sketch-Gruppe gefunden, die für uns ein Sketch gemacht hat. Genau. Das hat gut funktioniert. Auch die Sprachbarriere war da, aber konnte überwunden werden, konnte überschwunden werden. Aber hier spricht so ein bisschen Finnisch. Ein paar Worte hat man auf. Im Schlaf spreche ich überhaupt nicht Finnisch. Ja, glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, ne, ich glaube, Isländisch ist die schwerste Sprache der Welt, die so total abgefahrene Grammatik hat oder so. Da bewundere ich echt jeden, der Isländisch lernt, weil es ist so ein kleines Land. Macht gar keinen Sinn. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da eine coole Person ist, gering. Das ist so groß wie Bielefeld. Warum sollte man Bielefeldisch lernen? Nee, macht man nicht. Macht man nicht. Er gibt keinen Sinn. Er gibt keinen Sinn. Ja? Ägyptisch macht aber auch keinen Sinn. Ja, es ergibt keinen Sinn. Sorry, da hat er einen Punkt. Ja, aber auch das ist, wenn du jetzt als Franzose zuhörst, hörst du das vielleicht so, er gibt keinen Sinn, warum haben die Reden die von Ägypten? Ja, und du checkst gar nichts und so geht es mir auch, du verstehst Wörter völlig falsch und bist wo ganz anders. Du bist ganz woanders, das stimmt schon. Ich bin immer noch in meinem Handwerker-Dschungel,
ich bin immer noch im Umziehen und ...
Hast du schon eine Top-Farbe aufgemacht, einen Eimer-Farbe? Ich habe schon Eimer-Farbe aufgemacht. Ja, und dann wo legst du den Deckel hin? Ja, den lege ich umständlich, also den lege ich so um, dass man natürlich erst mal mit der ganzen Hand in die Innenseite des Deckels packt, dass man die ganze Hand voller Farbe ist, dann aber so eine Ist-es--Haltung entwickelt, dann legt man den auf den Boden, nicht ohne natürlich den halben Deckelinhalt auf dem schönen Laminat auszugießen, dann merkt man aber, dass man es abwischen kann und entwickelt dann so einen fahrlässigen Leichtsinn, und dann legt man den einfach um. Und dann braucht man ja, das ist ja, ich habe ja nicht so viel Zeug, dann habe ich nicht dieses Gitter, wo man so abrollen kann. Das vergesse ich ja dann auch im Baumarkt. Ich kaufte dann nicht noch so ein Gitter. Ich denke nicht mal an meinen Schlüssel, wenn ich das Haus verlasse, dann nehme ich dann nicht so ein Gitter im Baumarkt, mit welcher ich denke, bei mir ist dann die Farbe irgendwo abrollen. Nein, bei mir kommt der Pinsel in die Farbe und dann ist es gut. Dann wird geguckt, wenn es die Wohnung komplett die Farbe. Für welche Farbe hast du dich entschieden? Weiss. Ist es dann doch wieder weiss geworden? Aber ist es weiss oder ist es Eierschale oder ist es Creme? Nee, es ist alpiner weiss, wie man es liebt. Also knallweiss. Ich habe eine Wohnung mit sehr wenig so normalen weissen Wänden, die man streichen könnte. Ich habe viel Beton tatsächlich. Und diese Wände, die ich habe, die will man nicht farblich streichen. Da wollte ich schön einfach weiss bleiben. Basic. Ich habe ja mal, und da war für mich wirklich der Moment der brüderlichen Liebe am stärksten präsent, dass ich irgendwann in den Keller gezogen bin, in meinem Elternhaus. War ich im Keller, hatte ein ganz großes Kellerzimmer. Und dann hat meine Mutter das so ein bisschen für mich eindekoriert und hat manche Teile der Wände orange gemalt. Und nicht aber orange, sondern so orange mit so Mustern drin, so verschieden helles Orange und so über der Tür der Bereich, so dieses kleine Rechteck über der Tür, nicht alles, aber so kleine Teile.
Und mein Bruder sollte dann den Rest normal streichen. Und mein Bruder kam, bevor er gestrichen hat, so zu mir und meinte, du, soll ich diese Stellen, die Mama gemalt hat, aus Versehen übermalen? Mega! Und ich dachte mir, wow. Du bist der beste grosse Bruder der Welt. Du bist der beste, der ist Der ist bereit, den Anschiss meiner Mutter hin Kauf zu nehmen, dass er aus Versehen die orangen Sachen übermalt hat, weil er merkt oder weil er sich denken könnte, dass ich sowas nicht haben will.
Aber auch super nett, dass er überhaupt für dich malt.
Nee, das musste er irgendwie, weil er hat irgendwie das Auto meiner Mutter zu Schrott gefahren oder irgendwie sowas halt.
Aber es ist, nein, keine Ahnung.
Ist der Vater umgewacht, aber na gut, ja. Und dann hat er es dann komplett übermalt? Nee, ich habe dann gesagt, nee, passt schon. Finde ich eigentlich ganz schön. Ich finde es extrem schön. Kannst du nicht den Rest auch so orange malen? Dann hatte ich einfach einen Teil meines Zimmers war orange, so. Ist es bis heute vielleicht, man weiß es nicht genau. Weiss es nicht. Naja, das wurde dann weiterverkauft, das Haus. Ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt die neuen Besitzer das übermalt haben. Vielleicht ziehst du das so durch, weil niemand sich traut, dieses Orange wegzumachen. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Man muss ja auch dann erstmal was anderes deckendes drüber machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man einfach Weiss drüber belangen kann zum Beispiel. Ja, das ist so die Frage. Ich habe ja auch lange diese Warhammer-Miniaturen, diese kleinen Figurchen angemalt. Da ist auch ganz viel mit, wie scheinen die unteren Farben durch und so. Das ist für sehr viel Orange entschieden. Ja, und jetzt habe ich ein paar Handwerker, da habe ich einen Kohlelelektriker gefunden hier. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Elektrizität. Deswegen bin ich da froh, jemanden zu haben, auch weil ich ja fast gestorben bin. Und dann habe ich jetzt irgendwie so eine väterliche Nähe zu dem aufgebaut, weil der hat mich halt so ein bisschen vom Tode bewahrt, weil er dann dieses Kabel, was aus der Wand kam, für mich geschützt hat. Und seitdem nehme ich den wahr wie ein Familienmitglied und schreibe den auch mal immer privat und so. Und der kam jetzt wieder, hat dann aber eine Prügelei mit meinem Nachbarn angefangen. Weil mein Nachbar, also das ist nicht mein Nachbar, sondern da arbeiten auch Leute in diesem Haus. Und dann hat er den eingeparkt, der Handwerker, und dann kam es zu einem ganz dollen Streit. Und dann kam der Handwerker wieder rein und hat dann so mega aufgebracht und hat dann aus seiner Hand, wie man das halt so macht, nach Prügeleien. Ich weiß nicht, was man da macht, aber man knackt die dann so. Dann hat er so weiter sein Zeug zusammengesammelt. Ich habe draußen nur paar Schreie gehört. Und dann kam plötzlich eine andere Nachbarin, kam rein und hat gesagt, du Stefan, ich wollte nur sagen, dein Handwerker hat gerade Patrick von unten drunter geschlagen. Jetzt bist du zwischen Fronten gefangen. Wo sind die Loyalität? Und hinten im Haus höre ich nur so ein, der hat mich provoziert, der hat mich provoziert, der hat mich nett gefragt, ob ich meinen Wagen umparken kann. Und dann war ich so ein, ja, bin ich jetzt dafür verantwortlich, für diese Leute, die in meinem Haus was machen, in meiner Wohnung was machen? Bin ich für den jetzt verantwortlich, wenn er jetzt meinen Nachbarn umgebracht hätte? Ich glaube, du würdest schon zwei Wochen auch in Knast kommen. Einfach so als, ja, als kollateral, so zur Not. Bin ich jetzt schuld, weil ich habe den ja, der wäre ja ohne mich nicht auf dem Parkplatz gewesen. Ich glaube, so funktioniert recht nicht, dass du, der, der dafür sorgt, dass die Person dort ist. Alle, die an dem Zufall beteiligt waren, dass er an dem Ort ist, kommen auch mit den Knast. Ich glaube, so würde ein schlechter Anwalt argumentieren. Wäre die S-Bahn nicht zu spät gekommen, wäre mein Mandant gar nicht am Tatort gewesen. Also wer ist hier der Schuldige, die deutsche Bahn oder mein Mandant? Und alle so. Im deutschen Gericht gibt es nicht so viele Leute, da gibt es keine Geschworene, die dann klatschen. Da gibt es einen hinten, der klatscht, einer, der zuschaut, der die Tür macht, die Tür auf und zu. Aber jetzt bist du in der Loyalität gefangen. Wem schwörst du die Treue? Mein Handwerker. Handwerker oder Nachbarn? Handwerker über Nachbarn bei dir? Ja, bei dem jetzt schon, weil der hat mich ja mit meinem Leben, also dem verdranke ich, dass ich noch lebe und der hat meine Kabel gesichert. Tepa, du wohnst da seit zwei Wochen und machst schon alles falsch. Du hast dich schon mit den Nachbarn verscherzt. Ja, na gut. Die Leute wissen, dass du nicht auf ihrer Seite bist. Es gibt schon eine Inhouse-Fede mit dem Handwerker. Aber ich wurde jetzt in die WhatsApp-Gruppe aufgenommen, von daher ist auch alles wieder gut. Das Haus? Das ist der Wohnungsgemeinde. Es gibt bestimmt noch eine WhatsApp-Gruppe, wo alle drin sind und du nicht. Es gibt immer zu jeder WhatsApp-Gruppe noch mal eine exklusivere WhatsApp-Gruppe, wo nur ein Teil der Original-WhatsApp-Gruppe ist? Das sind nämlich so wenige Leute, also eigentlich müsste da, ich dachte immer, wer aktiv geschrieben, wurde dann nicht. Also seitdem ich drin war zumindest, wird dann nicht mehr viel geschrieben. Ja, und du deine, woher kommt Corona eigentlich, Bildchen gepostet und niemand hat antwortet. Ja, ich habe halt diese Artila Hildmann und Verschwungstheorien gepostet, wo man sich dann vielleicht, ja, hätte man sich vielleicht sparen können. Na Naja gut. Na gut. Ist ein klassischer Conversations da. Es wird nicht mehr viel, ja, dachte ich mal so, ein bisschen Diskurs anregen. Kam nicht so gut an, es wird nicht mehr so viel daran geschrieben. Aber ein kleiner, kleiner Erfolg, finde ich. Ich habe mir gedacht, also ich wurde auch schon vor ein paar Wochen aufgenommen und ich dachte mir wirklich, je früher, desto besserer Socializer bin ich.
Und ich wurde irgendwie nach zwei Wochen aufgenommen, was ganz toll war.
Wow, nicht schlecht. Ich wohne seit zwei Jahren in meiner Wohnung noch nie.
Du weißt noch nicht mehr, ob es eine WhatsApp-Gruppe gibt.
Null. Null.
Nein?
Ich glaube, letztens war die Polizei mal bei mir im Treppenhaus unterwegs, bin mitten in der Nacht aufgewacht, grosser Tumult im Treppenhaus und glaube ich ist ein Glas zerbrochen. Vielleicht hat mein Handwerker ganz heuer dich wieder provozieren lassen. Aber ich weiß, es kann auch sein, dass ich geträumt habe, ich war mir echt nicht sicher. Ich lag im Bett und dachte mir, ist das hier ein Traum gerade? Und dann bist du in diesem, wie merke ich das jetzt, ob das ein Traum ist? Und dann weiss man nicht genau, was man machen soll. Und dann so, ist das jetzt schon, wenn man denkt, das ist ein Traum, ist es dann schon kein Traum mehr? Ein Kreisel, André? Ein Kreisel, André? Relativ wenige Kreisel bei mir zu Hause, ein paar alte Beyblades, aber es sind Sammlersteuer. Das finde ich so clever, diesen Kreisel. Toll. Weil ich kann mir auch bei Gedanken kann ich mir oft das Ende nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir, wenn ich mir eine Bewegung vorstelle, kann ich mir die oft, kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, in meinem Kopf, aber ich kann mir das Ende nicht gut vorstellen. Und im Traum kann ich mir vorstellen, wie der Kreisel dreht, aber ich kann mir nicht diese, das ist ein Straucheln geraten und dann umkippen. Wann fällt er dann tatsächlich um? Das kann ich mir ganz schwer vorstellen, deswegen finde ich diese Idee, Fokusser von Nolan zu sagen, daran merkt man, ob man trauen soll oder nicht, finde ich ganz toll. Toll, Nolan. Gut gemacht, Nolan. Gut, Thumbs up, Nolan, Mr. Nolan. Thumbs up, Nolan, toll gemacht. Ich habe letztens auch, als ich von dem Podcast hier nach Hause gegangen bin, habe ich hier unter einem Auto ein kleines Kaninchen gesehen. Ja, ja, ja, ein weisses Kaninchen, ja, ein weisses Kaninchen. Das ist das Beste. Vor allem, Moment mal, weißt du, wo das ist? Ja, die wohnen direkt neben mir. Ich bin ja hierher, ist umgezogen, ich wohne direkt jetzt hier. Und genau da wohnen vier weisse Kaninchen, die sind wild. Ja, Moment mal, weil dann war es nämlich so, dann habe ich dieses Kaninchen gesehen und dachte mir erst mal, okay, krass. Ganz ruhig. Alice, Alice im Unterland. Ja, ich dachte auch, you're not in Ernenfeld anymore. Es war die erste Nacht, wo ich in einer neuen Wohnung war und plötzlich sah ich so vier weiße Kaninchen wunderbar rumhoppeln, direkt vor meinem Fenster. Ich dachte, wow. Aber ich dachte mir sofort, okay, ist es jetzt meine Verantwortung, muss ich das Kaninchen retten? Und dann gucke ich mich um, woher könnte das Kaninchen kommen? Und dann gibt es wirklich da eine Garage, wo auf das Garagentor riesengroß ein weisses Kaninchen gemalt ist. Ich dachte mir, okay, wahrscheinlich gehört das denen. Ich dachte, wie weird, habe ich mir die eingebildet und plötzlich sehe ich dann, gehe ich dann hier zu BTF und sehe auf diesem grossen Tor auch dieses weisse gemalte Kaninchen und dachte mir, okay, es gehört alles zusammen. Oder irgendwie muss ich meinem Pfad folgen und jetzt durch dieses Tor gehen oder sowas. Und ich sag mal so, die 14 Staffeln Detective Conan haben mich nicht unberührt belastet, denn ich habe haarscharf kombiniert, das Haus mit dem Kaninchen an der Wand und das Kaninchen, das von meinen Füssen ist, haben was miteinander zu tun. Was du nicht bedacht hast, es gibt noch drei weitere Kaninchen. Von denen wusste ich nichts. Ich weiß, ich habe ihr mittlerweile schon Namen gegeben, ich leh die jeden Abend. Du kannst die auseinanderhalten.
Ich kann die auseinanderhalten, klar.
Und tatsächlich sind die dann oft
vor meinem Fenster, spielen die und
eine Nachbarin, die die reinkam
und gesagt hat, dein Handwerker hat gerade Patrick von unten drunter geschlagen,
die wirft ja manchmal auch
Zeug hin.
Dann ist das ja der gleiche Nachbarin, weil ich bin dann zu diesem
Tor gegangen und dann saßen die im Garten
und dann habe ich so gerufen, so gehört ihnen das, dann habe ich erst mal zugegebenermaßen gegoogelt, Unterschied Kaninchen und Hase, damit ich nicht rufe, ist es Ihr Hase. Die müssen erst mal ganz voll voll angemacht, Gattung, Gattung, Kaninchen. Ja, Gattung, vier flauschiger Bunny und dann habe ich gerufen, hey, gehört Ihnen das Kaninchen, ja, ja, das passt schon so. Ja, ja. Da dachte ich mir, okay, ich dachte, ich bin jetzt der grosse Retter, bringt das verleute das Kaninchen nach Hause. Das denken jeden Tag regelmäßig Leute. Ich sehe da immer jeden Tag stehende Leute telefonieren davor, aber die wohnen da halt und die laufen frei rum. Mein Gott, aber kann man den nicht irgendwie ins Fell rasieren, so passt schon, ich wohne hier oder so. So ein Brandzeichen. Ja, so ein Brandzeichen oder halt so ein QR-Code, den man scannen kann. Weil ich fand das eine unangenehme Situation, so wenn du so eine Katze siehst, denkst du dir egal, aber wenn du ein freilaufendes Kaninchen siehst, denkst du dir, okay, hier ist was passiert. Warum denkst du da was ganz anderes? Naja, weil Kaninchen normalerweise nicht frei unterwegs sind, sondern eingesperrt sind. Wie es sich gehört für Kaninchen. Ja, so muss das auch sein. In so winzigen kleinen Käfigen. Winzig. Ich finde es ganz toll, die checken die Umgebung total, die haben auch keine Angst mehr vor Autos, ich werde auch irgendwann einen ganz furchtbaren Unfall sehen,
da bin ich mir sehr sicher.
Weil die sind immer direkt an der Straße und die sind befahren.
Ich würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn dein Elektriker da was mit zu tun hat.
Würde mich auch nicht wundern.
Wenn der beim Einparken, schön rückwärts einparken,
so zwei von vier Kaninchen erlegt.
Ja, mit seinem Magneto-artigen Elektroauto.
Wie hieß der Superheld-Gegner von Spider-Man mit der Elektro?. Wie hieß der Superheld Gegner von
Spider-Man mit der Elektro?
Zapdos.
Wie der Elektro?
Heißt der Elektro? Doktor Octopus.
Nein.
Die Amazing Spider-Man 2
gegen Spider-Man.
Ach, du meinst ...
Elektro, glaube ich. Heißt der Elektro?
Doktor Strom. Stefan Strom. The Amazing Spider-Man ... Steven ... Warte mal. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ja, Elektro, wow. Das war antiklimaktisch. Elektro heisst ja? Ja, das ist einfach Elektro. Aber es gibt ... Elektek heisst das Pokémon, ne? Elektek. Sogar ein Pokémon hat einen kreativeren Namen für ein Elektro-Pokémon als das Marvel-DC-Universe. Elektro. Elektro. Die mussten noch richtig schwitzen für ihre Namen, ne, Spider-Man. Ja, vor allem, das ist doch, also wenn du wirklich in-persona-Spider-Man bist und jemand sagt, ich bin Elektro, dann würdest du doch nicht sagen, oh nein, Elektro, ein furchtbarer Gegner. Du würdest doch sagen, ehrlich, das ist ihr Name, Elektro? Sie haben sich den Namen Elektro gegeben, weil sie Elektro-Blitze absondern? Aber geben sich Superhelden immer selber den Namen oder ist das so wie bei Fanta, dass dann andere Leute anfangen, das zu sagen und dann so, ja, jetzt bin ich halt Mr. Bunny oder so oder Bunny Hop Hop, weil ich halt hoch springen kann.
Eigentlich dachte ich Jumpman, aber gut, jetzt bin ich Bunny Hop.
Bunny Hop Hop. Ist jetzt, ja, okay.
Hätte jetzt ein Hop gereicht.
Hey, ich bin Jumpman.
Jumpman?
Nein, du bist Bunny Hop Hop.
Ach, Bunny Hop Hop, lauft schnell, yes sir, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, ah, fuck.
Fucking it all.
Kannst du nicht machen?
Spider Boy.
Spider Kid, Spiderboy. Spider-Kid, Spiderboy. Spiderboy. Ne, ich bin Spider-Man. Also, man, ich bin doch schon gross. Das sieht man im Kostüm nicht so gut, das ist eine optische Täuschung. Ich bin Spider-Man. Ich bin viel grösser. Spider-Guy. Spider-Dude? Bin ich Spider-Dude, ich bin Spider-Man. Oh, apropos, wir haben Nachricht bekommen, wir haben Nachrichten bekommen, denn wir haben ja letzte Woche dazu aufgerufen, dass unsere Zuhörerschaft ausschwärmen soll und die gesamte A, B, C und D-Prominenz Hollywoods anschreiben soll über ihre E-Mail-Adressen. Meine wurde erraten, wie ist es bei dir? Meine wurde auch einmal erraten, ja, tatsächlich. Einmal, aber auch bei mir noch nur. Bei mir auch nur einmal, es war nicht, ich glaube, es ist nicht so unfassbar schwer, aber es ist tatsächlich passiert und wir haben tatsächlich eine Antwort bekommen und zwar haben wir eine Antwort bekommen von Saoirse Ronan. Ich glaube, so spricht man sie aus. Saoirse Ronan haben wir tatsächlich eine Antwort bekommen an uns, und zwar an saoirse.ronan.gmx.de, die schreibt, okay, you got me, I created a very simple and generic email address some years ago, haha funny. Also tatsächlich, wir haben eine Antwort bekommen von Saoirse Ronan, ob das wirklich die echte Miss Ronan ist oder ein Hörer. Es ist ein fanfasischer Hörer,, der lustigerweise jetzt, serscherronen at gmx.de, schreibt ihm oder ihr mal bitte. Genau, jetzt wiederum die neue Aufgabe. Schreibt eine E-Mail an serscher.ronen at gmx.de und nehmt den Kontakt auf. Und so geht das immer weiter. So geht es immer weiter. Jetzt kreieren wir schon Fake-E-Mail-Adressen. Es ist ein bisschen so wie Impersonator, nur virtuell mit E-Mail-Adressen. Oder jetzt müsst ihr mit anderen prominenten E-Mail-Adressen an Saoirse Ronan schreiben. Und dann könnt ihr screenshotten. Und dann so tun, als hättet ihr euch bei einem Filmshoot gesehen. Jetzt macht ihr timothy.chalamet.netcolone.de und jetzt schreibt dann an Gmx von Saoirse Ron und sagt, wow, Commit by Your Name war ein toller Film, oder? Und es entsteht ein riesiges Fake-Netzwerk von Fake-Promis, die miteinander connect sind. Irgendwann weiss die ganze Welt nicht mehr, wer was ist und was Und warum reden die alle deutsch? Das sind tolle Fragen, die wir uns stellen. Warum sind die alle bei telemedialonline.de unterwegs? gut, das ist nun mal die beste Hotline. Was sind die besten E-Mail-Adressen? Ich bin iCloud-Fan, ich bin web.de-Weich-Fan, ja, harvard.de ist glaube ich die beste. Oh, stefan.de ist at harvard.de. Gibt es die noch? Wahrscheinlich schon. Es gibt einen Stephen Titz at Harvard? Oh, ich darf bei manchen Websites tatsächlich nicht meine echte E-Mail, ich musste mir eine neue E-Mail-Adresse neulich anlegen, weil TIT nicht im Namen vorkommen darf. Aber es ist mein Name. Stefan Titz, das TIT steht für Fun. Das TIT steht für Fun. Ja, aber ich darf manchmal nicht meine E-Mail-Adresse benutzen, weil da TIT drin vorkommt. Ja. Und manche sagen, nee, sie können nicht so obszönen Schwachsinn reinnehmen. Deswegen glaube ich, würde Harvard generell sagen, nee. Ich hatte auch mal, es gab mal von Kelloggs diese geniale Aktion, dass wenn man irgendwie zehn Packungen gekauft hat, easy ist ein Wochenende für mich, konnte man die Codes alle zusammenfügen und dann durfte man sich einen Löffel bedrucken lassen. Einen Löffel mit seinem Namen bedrucken lassen.
Und dann musste man sich auf so einer Online-Webseite, also einer echten Online-Webseite, sich anmelden und konnte dann seinen Namen eingeben, der auf den Löffel gedruckt wird. Ich habe natürlich erstmal alles probiert, irgendwie Holocaust, irgendwie holocaustlüge.de oder irgendwie sowas.
Kellog.
Alles ausprobiert, ging alles nicht, bis ich dann tatsächlich irgendwann nicht meinen Namen, sondern den Namen von einer Person, der ich sagen geschenkt habe, gemacht habe. Nichts beste Geschenk aller Zeiten, aber gut. Ich hatte nur einen Short und ich habe es probiert, warum nicht? Ja, wow. Es ist eine lange Reihe von meinen weirden Tinder-Geschenken. Ein Löffel mit dem Namen der Glücklichen drauf. In falsch geschrieben. In falsch geschrieben. Hanna ohne H hinten. Ach so, ich dachte drei N. Nee, Hanna mit zwei, ach so scheiße. Hanna na na na na na na na na, dachte ich. Naja gut. Und na ja. Ja, eine gute Reihe auf jeden Fall. Die ist gegangen und hat den Löffel mitgenommen. Ich weiß nicht, braucht man nicht. Ich habe auch noch eine solche Zollstöcke gesehen, wo man seinen Namen an den Doppel draufhauen kann. Einwerkerkönig. Braucht man nicht. Ich habe den längsten auf dem Bau. So, das ist doch dein Humor. Schöner Baumarkthumor. Das finde ich sehr lustig, ich habe den längsten auf dem Bau. Gags, die man im Baumarkt finden kann, sind doch die besten. Oder so auf Schnittbrettern. Ja. So auf Schneidebrettern so, wow. Top 20 ja so auf schneidebrettern so war top 20 gags auf schneidebretter okay nummer 20 schon eine gurke zum frühstück gibt es schon wie heißt der drink mit dem mit der gurke drin ja okay was du schneidest schon eine gurke zum frühstück so So früh schon Gin Tonic, ist es Platz 20, komm, da muss noch Platz da oben sein. Ich habe aber dann glaube ich die Kategorie nicht ganz verstanden. Schneidebretter. Ja, Schneidebretter. So zum Gurkenschneiden. Ja. Okay. Pass auf deine Finger auf. Platz 18,
Schneidebrett, Training für ein Schneidebrettbauch.
Lass es vor, pass auf deine Finger auf.
Du, ich habe die Liste nicht gemacht.
Doch!
Doch.
Ja, aber ich kann nicht mehr unter deine gehen.
Aber muss es jetzt besser werden, oder was?
Per Definition schon. Platz 18? Auf Platz 18 der besten Schneidebrett-Jokes ist ... Aber hier kann man keine Schneidebretter schneiden. Auf Platz 17 der Schneidebrett-Jokes, das ist kein Mauspad. Ist ein kleiner Insider, aber muss sein. Weil tatsächlich hat sich mal mein Bruder zu Weihnachten ein Mauspad aus Holz gewünscht. Er dachte so, ja, ich finde das irgendwie cool, so Sachen aus Holz, irgendwie so, ein schönes Mauspad aus Holz. Und ich habe einfach kein Mauspad aus Holz gefunden und habe ihm ein Schneidebrett geschenkt. Ein Amazon-Schneidebrett. Kann man denn darauf eine Maus gut bewegen? Ja, locker. Und er hat sich nicht beschwert, er war zufrieden. Aber die Maus wurde immer ein bisschen schmaler. Ein bisschen weggerasmet. Tatsächlich habe ich ein Holzmauspad gefunden und bestellt. Das hatte aber nur so das Muster wie Holz sowieso, so Eichenholz. Aber es war aus Plastik. Und dann dachte ich mir, das kann ich ihm nicht schenken, das geht nicht. Und dann habe ich ihm einfach so ein Holzschneidebrett geschenkt. Ich verstehe Mauspads nicht. Doch, Mauspads sind wichtig. Ja, ist es nicht viel einfacher, einfach die Maus anzupassen, dass die auf jedem Untergrund funktioniert? Kommt auf den Tisch an. Es gibt ja manche Tische, die reflektieren anders, da ist es dann nicht gut. Und du willst ja, dass es immer gleich ist. Ja. Wenn du auf eine LAN-Party gehst, nimmst du ein Mauspad mit deiner Maus und es ist gleich. Dann musst du dich nicht an einen neuen Tisch gewöhnen. Hey, sorry. Da hast du andere DPI-Abgreifzahlen. Das ist ganz anders. Also da musst du schon gucken. Ich finde, du wärst ein guter Vater. Jaja, nee, das muss schon sein. Also darauf würde ich aufpassen, dass meine Kinder vernünftige Mauspads haben. Okay, dann nehme ich mein Mauspad mit Papa. Ich habe tatsächlich mal, als ich klein war, habe ich meinem Vater mal ein Mauspad geschenkt, von einem Bild, das ich selber gemalt habe, mit einem Computer drauf. Mein Vater ist ja ein großer Apple-Fan. Und dann habe ich ein Mauspad gemalt und dann konnte man das irgendwo hinschicken und dann haben die ein Mauspad draus gemacht und auch die Tastatur kreuz und quer die Buchstaben, also wirklich, da hätte man sich nicht einfach mal neben eine Tastatur setzen können, um die abzumalen, nö, ich dachte, siebenjähriger Florentin denkt sich, das kriege ich schon hin, die aus dem Gedächtnis die Buchstaben abzumalen, alles falsch. Aber habe ich noch nicht mal versucht. dir jetzt ein Wort vorstellst, Hallo zum Beispiel, könntest du es vor dir, mit beiden Fingern, könntest du es glaube ich gut eintippen. Ich glaube, du kennst die Position der verschiedenen Buchstaben, vielleicht nicht sofort, aber in Korrelation zueinander. Also Hallo könntest du es gut eintippen, Stefan könnte ich auch. Wenn ihr-Jean. Ich weiß weder wie man das schreibt noch wie man das ausspricht. Von daher nicht, aber wenn ihr euch mal so eine Tastatur vorstellt und macht die Augen zu und ihr müsstet was tippen, ihr könnt das gut tippen. Deswegen glaube ich, kann man sich relativ gut aus dem Kopf eine Tastatur vorstellen. Ihr müsst einfach nur dann ab und zu mal ein Wort mit Q
schreiben, dann weiss man ja, es
querzujob fängt sich an.
Oder auf dem H ist ja so ein Huppel drauf für die Finger,
für die Anpassung.
Nee, auf dem F und auf dem J.
Aber H ist in der Mitte, ne?
H ist neben dem J. Na gut.
Alles wieder verlernt, alles wieder verlernt.
Naja, aber das kann man glaube ich ganz gut machen.
Schreibst du auf dem Dunkeln?
Nee. Generell bin ich ein heller Typ. Ich brauche immer viel helles Licht. Meine Wohnung ist immer heller leuchtet. Ja, soll man nicht. Aber mit LIDs. Das ist deine kleine Sünde. Das nimmst du mit ins Grab. Das nehme ich mit. Gut, er war ein heller Mensch. Er wollte es hell und er war nicht stolz drauf. Und wir alle haben unsere Schwächen und wer der Erste ohne Sünde ist, wer der im Dunkeln ist, werfe den ersten Stein. Auch so bei, ich glaube, auch so Beichtpfarrer kriegen teilweise so scheiss Sünden. Ja, ist das so, Beichtpfarrer. Beichtpfarrer, glaubefarrer die dann auch so ich habe gesündigt ich habe zu viele lampen in meiner wohnung oh komm alter andere leute werfen ihre tochter aus dem fenster aus versehen und du fängst ja an ihre grösste sünde ist ziemlich Langweilend. Ja. Snap nach ihren Schuhen.
Raus, nächster!
Nächst!
Bisschen wie The Voice, nur als Beichte. Dass man sich erst umdreht, wenn es spannend wird. Ich höre, ich höre und dann drehen sich die Pfarrer immer um, in der Hoffnung einen geilen kleinen Jungen zu sehen. Aber das ist eine gute, das ist auch was für was. Einen geilen Messdiener. Telefone, falls ihr zuhört. Einen kleinen geilen knackigen. Okay, alles klar. Ja, und wie betätigen sie den Knopf mit der Hand oder wie machen sie es? Ja, so. Das ist doch eigentlich The Confession, man muss beichten und wie viele, wie viele Pfarrer sich umdrehen. So hat man dann aber Prominente natürlich, irgendwie irgendwie Kardinal, wer heißt der, Woelki, lustiger Name, aus Köln, Kardinal Ratzinger, sieht auf einem Auge nicht mehr, aber kann trotzdem noch rumkommen. Beide Päbste fände ich ja gut. Boah, alter Pabst versus Pabst. Oh, das finde ich sehr gut. Das wäre geil. Boxen aber dann. Also Scrabble. Aber welche Sprache ist dann die Frage? Sprache des Herrn. Sprache des Herzens. Sprache des Herrn. Finnisch. Oder so Latein wahrscheinlich. Finde ich gut. Ich glaube eh, dass wir coole Pfarrer in Deutschland haben. Also da sind weirde Gestalten dabei. Aber die sieht man nicht, die kriegt man nicht mit.
Ich habe neulich das Wort zum Sonntag oder zum Radio gehört, grauenhaft. Also wirklich, ich finde es so, das war ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender und die müssen eine gewisse Zeit ihrer Senderzeit Kirchen zur Verfügung stellen und so. und das war der so ein platter Drecksbeitrag, wo man sagt, der hat jetzt gerade nur das Wort erhalten bekommen, nicht weil er gut schreiben kann oder einen cleveren Gedanken hat oder so, sondern weil er ein Typ von der Kirche ist. Deswegen durfte er im Radio was sagen für eine Minute. Finde ich nicht okay. Ich finde, auch da musste man zumindest in einer Redaktion mal irgendwie auf Coolness. Irgendwie eine witzige Top-Ten-Liste oder so oder irgendwie die Top-10-Heiligen oder irgendwie. Ein bisschen aufpeppen. Ja, es war ja schon so peppig gemeint. Aber es war im Prinzip ein Was du nicht willst, was man dir tut, das will gar keinem anderen zu. Ja, mein Gott. Auf eine Minute gestreckt. Das Jahr fünf hat angerufen. Mit FC Köln-Referenzen, um so ganz cool zu sein. Ja. Kant hat angerufen. Er hat Urheberrecht angemeldet. Schenke ich euch. Könnte er haben. Echt, Immanuel? Könnte er haben. Klar. Guter Name finde ich, Immanuel. Immanuel ist super. Was ist da Manuel? Manuel Kant, ich glaube, er wäre nicht so berühmt geworden, wenn er Manuel Kant. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das Immanuel macht schon viel im. Manu kann? Glaube ich überhaupt nicht. Warum kann man da einfach
vor Manuel noch das Imm packen?
Kann man das vor einem Namen auch?
Ich glaube, wenn du Manuel heisst, kannst du dir, wenn du 18 bist,
zum Namensamt gehen und sagen, kannst du dir noch so einen Addon holen.
Du kannst Imanuel werden, Emanuel kannst du werden,
Emanuela, je nachdem, kannst alles werden, was du willst.
Manuela.
Manuela, ja, du kannst noch so Add-ons kaufen, von vorne und hinten.
Manuelon.
Manuelo.
Ja?
Manolo vielleicht auch.
Was du möchtest.
Manfred.
Ja, es gibt ein extra Amt dafür.
Aber das ist bei dem Namen besonders, ne?
Das ist besonders.
Ich als Stefan kann Stefano vielleicht noch.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Estefan?
Das wird ganz, ganz ungern.
Estefan, ja?
Vielleicht, vielleicht, aber ansonsten wird das sehr, sehr ungern gesehen. Aber es gibt solche Namen, auf jeden Fall. Eine Freundin von mir hat sich mal umbenannt. Die Familie hat sich umbenannt. Die Nachnamen haben die? Nachnamen umbenannt, ja. Ja? Nee, die haben nur einen Buchstaben hinzugefügt. Oder wie haben die sich... Einen Buchstaben dazu? Ja, ein Buchstaben dazu, weil der Name ist wie ein Vorname. Und damit die das klar abtrennen wollten zum Vornamen. Ah, Manuels. Was ja, also heißen die nicht, aber was ja oft gemacht wird, ist Tim. Wenn du Tim mit Nachnamen heisst, machst du entweder ein H noch und dann zwei M oder nur zwei M. Him? Nee, Tim. Mit T-H-I-M-M oder T-I-M-M. Ja, aber warum machst du denn Erinnerungen, die man nicht hört? Nee, das macht man häufig, damit man es vom Vornamen unterscheidet, dann irgendwie optisch auch. Ja, ich frage mich jetzt nicht, gucke mich nicht einmal deinen grossen Augen und deinen fragenden Blicken, kleines Kind. Aber mal ganz kurz, man kann doch, wenn zwei Leute heiraten, kann man doch einen Doppelnamen machen. Kann man. Kann man, wenn jetzt zwei Leute, die denselben Nachnamen haben, wenn die heiraten, kann man dann auch einen Doppelnamen machen. Kann man Tim Tim Tim heißen? Familie Tim Tim. Gibt das? Ich glaube schon. Wie gut wäre das denn? Das wäre mega, hört man selten. Timothy Tim Tim. Stell dir vor, du gehst zur Schule, erster Schultag, Namenssitz wird aufgerufen, Timothy Tim Tim,nt mich Timmy Tim Tim. Und alle so, okay, sie überspringen direkt drei Jahre, sie sind in der vierten Klasse, los geht's. Cooles Dude der Welt. Ja, Vorsprung, Abi, hier heisst ihr Abi, macht's gut. Hier ist ihr Abi, Timmy Tim Tim Tim. Alter, wie gut. Fantastisch. Mega, das finde ich richtig gut. Selten, selten gehört. Was sind die besten, aber ganz kurz, sorry, muss dann die gesamte Familie, auch alle Cousins und Onkels und Omas und Tanten, alle da dann zum Amt? Weil du kannst ja nicht, ein Teil der Familie können ja nicht Namen ändern und alle anderen nicht. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe auch schon oft überlegt, mir das eh zu kaufen. Für Tietze. Für ein langes Tietze. Estefane? Du willst echt ein E kaufen? Ja, das lange Tietze. Aber kann man doch nicht ... Wäre das nicht eine gute Pointe für diesen Podcast eigentlich? Wäre das nicht die beste Pointe des Running Gags, dass ich irgendwann mir den Namen gesetzlich ändere? Ja. Aber kannst du nicht mit jemandem zum Amt gehen, der das eh loshaben will und dann so, ja, dann nehme ich's? Dann müsst ihr beide nicht zahlen. Ja, vor allem, du kriegst ja Geld, wenn du einen Buchstaben wegnehmen lässt und du musst ja Geld bezahlen, wenn du einen bekommst. Wo käme man da hin, wenn jeder hier Buchstaben kriegt wie Rüben auf dem Feld? Und deswegen haben wir beschlossen, wir tauschen einfach den Buchstaben, wir machen einen Buchstaben-Swap. Ja, uns geht's ja gerade finanziell ein bisschen schlecht und deswegen, Kinder, tut's mir leid, ich habe drei Buchstaben von unserem Nachnamen verkauft. Aber Mama, ist ja nicht schlimm, weil wir heissen ja Schöneberger mit Nachnamen. Wir haben ja noch eine Menge Buchstaben. Wir heissen nur noch Schönepp. Wir haben mir leid. Du hast so viele Buchstaben verkauft. Ich habe Ärger verkauft. Du hast Ärger verkauft? Ich habe Ärger komplett verkauft. Du machst immer nur Ärger. Okay, aber dafür kommen wir jetzt zwei Monate über die Runden.
Wie heisst es denn? Schönepp? Schönepp, ja. Aber das B hättest du doch wenigstens auch noch verkaufen können.
So weit kommt es nicht. Das bleibt uns noch. Aber Schönepp ist der weirdste Name. Schönepp ist okay, das könnte ungarisch sein.
Aber es ist doch besser als Familie Schön zum Beispiel.
Das ist doch der Unsinn, Schön, dann sagst du, du bist ja gar nicht schön. Oder Schöne.
Komm du mal in die Schule erstmal, kannst du sehen, was Nachname eigentlich bedeutet, dass dir das ganze Zeug um die Ohren geworfen wird. Schöneb. Schöneb, das könnte polnisch sein oder so, mein Gott, ist das exotisch. Schöneb ist okay. So. Okay. Und dein Vornamen hast du nichts gemacht, Alexandra? Nein. Wieso nicht? Aber pass mal auf, Zacharias. Wenn es H auf H kommt, dann ist weg das Z. Ich habe ein bisschen Bock auf Zack, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe Bock auf Z, A, C. Wenn du 18 bist, kannst du deinen Namen verkaufen. Bis dahin gehört der Name mir. Und wenn du Acharias heißen willst, mein Lieber, dann schwer dich jetzt weiter. Ich nehme dein Z weg. Dann kaufe ich mir das Z.
Na gut, kriegst du immer ein B hin.
Heißt er Bacharias.
Da kannst du mal schauen, was dann die Leute sagen.
Auf dem Schulhof.
Ich glaube, Namen verändern kostet 80 Euro.
Ja, 80 Euro.
Und ich verstehe immer nicht, woher diese Summe kommt.
Aber gibt es da einen Cooldown, dass du zumindest ein Jahr lang warten musst?
Kostet ein E eigentlich mehr als ein Y? Ich glaube, ein E gibt es genug. Aber da muss es doch so einen Cooldown geben. Du kannst ja nicht jeden Tag deinen Namen ändern, oder? Du kannst ja nicht einmal Pick, Pock und Puff heißen und dann immer so inzwischen den drei Namen protieren. Für das Namensänderungsverfahren sind das bei Änderungen des Familiennamens von 2,50 bis hin zu 1.022 Euro pro Person. Bei Änderungen des Vornamens sind es immer inzwischen 2,50 und 255 Euro. 50 und 1000. Das sind ja Domainpreise. Aber stell dir vor, du gehst hin und sagst, er macht 2,50. Warum jetzt nur 2,50 für uns? Wieso denn 2,50? Es wird mehr geben. Dann gibst du einen Fünfer und kriegst 2,50 Euro zurück. Laut Namensänderungsgesetz lässt sich der Familienname wie auch der Vorname nur ändern, wenn der wichtige Grund das rechtfertigt. Doch was ist wichtig und was ist nicht wichtig? Darüber schweigt das Gesetz. Ja, ist immer das Problem, das Gesetz schweigt. Nämlich das findet man erst in der dazu erlassenen allgemeinen Verwaltungsforschung. Als wichtig genug für eine Namensänderung gelten demnach unter anderem ein Name, der die Mehrheit mit anstössigen Gedanken verbindet, Titz, passt, ein lächerlich klingender Name oder der zu entspricht. Wie zum Beispiel im Gesetzestext. Titz, hey, ein Name, der sich nur schwer schreiben bzw. aussprechen lässt oder eine Rückkehr zum früheren Nachnamen.
Ja und Nazi-Namen, oder?
Ich denke, die kann man bestimmt auch da aussprechen.
Nein, nein, nein die nicht.
Die sind nicht lächerlich. Warum nicht? Lächerlich im Namen.
Lächerlich, steht das Wort lächerlich eigentlich im Grundgesetz irgendwo?
Ich weiß nicht, dusselig? Kann ja jemand mal eine Search machen? Blöde, dusselig. Was macht eigentlich, gute Frage, liebe Leute, unsere Petition. Ja, wir kitzeln die Demokratie mal wieder am Bauch und gucken, was rauskommt. Bislang hat sich noch nicht allzu viel getan. Wir haben eine Petition gestartet, den ersten Artikel des Grundgesetzes zu fällen. Wir haben da ausgeboten, es müssen zwei Drittel des Bundestages zustimmen. Aber ich habe verschiedene Sachen gehört. Ich habe auch gehört, dass man das nicht ändern kann, die Grundgesetze. Ich habe gehört, es braucht einen bewaffneten Putsch. Also, dass wir den Bundestag stürmen müssen und putschen müssen, den Plenarsaal stürmen und dann irgendwie so ein Stürmer. Da muss man Glocke kommen und wenn man die Glocke erreicht hat, dann ist offiziell geputscht, weil damit halt nicht so viel sterben müssen muss man nur wie so beim Klettern einmal an die Glocke kommen, putschglocke, und dann okay und dann müssen alle, ja jetzt, was wollt ihr für eine Regierung? Monarchie, Anarchie, Demokratie, was wollt ihr? Kann man dann zumindest, hat man dann jemanden, der einem die aufzählt, Weil ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, wie viele es gibt. Naja, also so viele gab es noch nicht. Aristokratie. Oligarchie natürlich, auch wenn man immer gern gesehen, ansonsten, ja, wir können Würfel entscheiden lassen oder einen Huhn. Theokratie? Ja, ein bisschen aus der Munde gekommen, aber könnte man machen. 643 Leute haben bislang die 6.43, Demokratie? Ja, ein bisschen aus der Mutter gekommen, aber könnte man machen. 643 Leute haben bislang die Position unterschrieben. 643 Demokratie und gläubige Bürger. Woher kommt das eigentlich? Das haben wir nicht wie eingestellt. Wenn wir jetzt eingestellt hätten, 500.
Wir sind mit 500 zugegeben. Hätten wir dann schon das Gesetz geändert? War es unser Fehler, dass wir nicht eingegeben haben?
Wir haben zu hoch gepokert. Wir haben gesagt, 100.000 kriegen wir locker hin. Aber da haben wir nicht mit der Demokratie- Verdrossenheit unserer Hörer gerechnet. Alle schlafen. Hallo, aufwachen da! Aufwachen, liebe Demokratiefreunde. Komplett durchgeschlafen. Das Problem ist, wenn man laut genug schreit, weckt man nicht nur Demokratiefreunde, sondern auch die Feinde. Oh, wow. Nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht, Stefan Dieter. Ich war, ich bin ein komplettes Wrack. Ich habe mich entschlossen, ich will ein bisschen in Form kommen. Ich war gestern joggen. Ich war, glaube ich, seit dreieinhalb Jahren nicht mehr joggen. Ich dachte, es kommt für Monate oder so. Nee, nee, nee, wirklich schon ewig lang. Mein Körper hat auch gesagt so, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Was ist das? Er war so Larry David, wenn er jemanden sieht, der dann mit Sandalen und Socken läuft. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, keine Diskussion. Ich habe einen kompletten Muskelkater heute, das ist lächerlich, obwohl ich 20 Minuten gejoggt bin. Ich habe immer einen Joggen, Muskelkater. Ja, furchtbar. Vor allem Muskelkater ist die dümmste Idee des Körpers, der dir einfach sagt, ach du willst, dass wir gesünder werden, du willst mehr Lungenvolumen haben, du willst, dass wir ein bisschen Fett abbauen. Ne, lass mal, hier hast du einen schönen Muskelkater. Hier, Risse, Risse im Muskel. Risse, zerreiss dir deine Muskeln. Das sind Risse im Muskel. Und du denkst dir, warum, warum werde ich nicht belohnt, warum kriege ich nicht irgendwie schöne Gefühle in meinem Körper? Wobei ich finde Muskelkater ja was Gutes. Ja, man kann dann keinen Sport machen. Man kann dann keinen Sport machen. Man denkt sich am Tag danach, heute kein Sport, weil ich habe Muskelkater. Heute keinen Sport, ich habe gestern Sport gemacht, mein Körper erinnert mich daran. Und es fühlt sich wirklich an, als hätte es so etwas gemacht. Und ich finde, Muskelkater fühlt sich um so an wie, ah, okay, jetzt bilden sich Muskeln. Es ist exakt das Gegenteil, weil Muskeln sind gerissen oder die heilen ja jetzt. Und Muskelkater, finde ich, fühlt sich auch an, mein Körper verbrennt jetzt fett.
Weil diese
kleinen Wunden zu flicken,
erfordert ja auch ein bisschen Energie des Körpers.
Oh, wirklich?
Kann man sich selber verletzen
und dann braucht der Körper Kalorien, um die
zu heilen?
Du kannst einfach rauchen anfangen, das ist ein Nervengift.
Der Körper braucht das,
muss dann mehr Kalorien verbrennen, um das abzubauen. Also ja, du kannst dich selber verletzen.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen zu selbstbewusst gesagt, dafür, dass ich eigentlich nicht so viel weiß darüber. Man, stimmt, man nimmt ja ab beim Rauchen, aber ist das, weil der Gift abbauen muss, oder wie? Ja, glaube ich schon, Nervengift abbauen muss. Salz? Und wenn ich jetzt einen Schönkuchen esse? Ein Snack, musst du ja den Kuchen abverdauen und das kostet Kalorien. Genial. Stimmt, es gibt doch irgendwie so dieses eine Gemüse, ich glaube Sellerie oder so, wo man beim Kauen mehr Kalorien verbraucht. Das kann wirklich sehr gut sein. So wie ich meinen Spargel schäle, auch bei mir Spargel. Ja? Ja. Weil ich da nicht so gut schäle. Ich bin nicht so gut im Schälen. Zu viel oder was? Am Ende hast du noch so einen Zahnstocher dünnen Spargel übrig. Spaghetti aus Spargel. Oh, Spagletti. Nicht schlecht. Es gibt auch so Spaghetti-Maschinen, wo du so Spaghetti-Eis machen kannst. Da kannst du dann auch Spargel durchstecken, dann hast du Spaghettiinis. Spaghettiinis? Genial! Und du sagst, ich soll kein Chef-Table mehr anschauen, ich revolutioniere die Küche hier gerade. Ihr müsst nur zu. Ich sag nur, fang mal beim Rührei an oder sowas. Du fängst dann direkt bei neuen Gerichten an. Tatsächlich, mir hat jemand eine App, ich habe hier leider kein Internet immer, aber mir hat jemand eine App empfohlen, da muss man bei der App eingeben, was man falsch gemacht hat beim Essen und die App sagt einem, wie man es wieder gerade biegen kann. Das ist so die gerade bieg App, so wenn du schreibst dann rein, es ist viel zu salzig und schrecklich verbrannt und dann einfach so die Milch, Milch oder halt Milch, Milch passt schon, aber finde ich eine geile App-Idee, einfach so dieses wie kriege ich es wieder gerade. Das ist eigentlich eine geniale Idee für alles, wo du eingibst Strafzettel. Und sauer? Was wäre die Lösung? Sorry. Entschuldigung, mein Körper verbränt gerade so viel Energie. Weil er gähnen muss. Ja. Ich habe nicht nachgeguckt. Was ist gähnen eigentlich? Gehirn durchlüften, habe ich mal gehört. Ich habe gehört, du hast zu wenig Sauerstoff und der Körper sagt, komm, gib mir noch mal einen guten Schuss jetzt hier. Einen dicken Sauerstoff. Und warum ist Gähnen ansteckend? Was hat das für einen Hintergrund? Weil der Körper merkt, scheiße, atmen habe ich auch schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Habe ich auch schon lange nicht mehr, weil der will das auch. Das kennt man ja auch. Wenn der Bruder was geschenkt bekommt bei der Nacht, will man das ja auch haben. Ja. Der kriegt Luft jetzt, kommt man auch an zu gähnen. Ja, aber was hat das denn? Ich sag mal so, du atmest ja meistens nicht bewusst, sondern du lässt es so nebenbei herlaufen, aber der Körper ist ja auch nicht perfekt. Der vergisst mal zwei Minuten lang zu atmen und dann so stupft jemand an so, wir haben nicht mehr geatmet, zwei, zwei Minuten. Oh, wirklich? Oh, shit, ja, dann mach jetzt mal einen grossen, ein, ne, passt schon wieder. Wir gleichen das aus, mal einen grossen Gähner und dann kommen wir da rein. Und wie viele von euch haben jetzt gegähnt, weil wir über Gähnen sprechen? Auch spannend. Alle, außer die Psychopathen unter euch, kann man daran erkennen, dass die nicht von Gähnen angesteckt werden und dass die Leute den Kopf abschlagen. Also wenn ihr nicht gegähnt habt, dann seid ihr Psychopathen. Dann müsst ihr euch verhaften lassen. Wenn ihr sagen, ich bin Hannibal Lektor. Lektor. Vor der Tat. Hannibal. Lektor. Geht es wie in Vanilla Sky, dass man sich verhaften lässt, bevor man eine Tat begeht? So eine Zukunftstat? Minority Report mässig. Verhaftet werden kann. Oder Vanilla Sky, je nachdem. Nee. Minority. Ansieds aber. Oder Twelve Monkeys. Weiß ich nicht. Schönes Liste. Looper, je nachdem. Nee, das ist Quatsch. Unterschiedlich. Looper? Ja. Auch einen Film, den ich mir ... Schaut euch mal Looper an. Und ... Also ohne Scheisse der Filmkritiker, der weit ausholt und dann sagt, ach schaut ihn euch an, der ist echt gut. Nee, weil ich behaupte jetzt mal, dass den niemand so richtig versteht. Und alle, die ihn beim ersten Mal gucken, verstehen, lügen. Weil man kann so mit so ein paar Floskeln, kann man sich immer so zurechtbiegen, dass ich es verstanden habe und so. Oh, die Cinematographie ist fantastisch. Und du musst einfach nur sagen, nee, das ist dein Vater. Also selbstbewusst argumentieren. Aber das ist alles Bullshit, das verstehe ich alles nicht. Ich glaube ja, man hätte schon von Anfang an das Ende erahnen können. Wenn du in der ersten Szene genau hinguckst, siehst du schon Hinweise auf die letzte Szene. Zum Beispiel die Anordnung der Figuren im Raum oder auch wie das Licht fällt, kannst du schon direkt sehen, wie das Ende eigentlich ist. Also das ist ganz clever, dass da schon so ein Foreshadowing mit Schatten, also total, auch wenn man Meter eben, total genial gemacht wurde und deswegen eigentlich perfekt. Von daher kannst du machen. Schnitt fand ich super, Schnitt fand ich super. Mit Film. Mit Filmschnitt, ja, also dass der immer einen wichtigen Moment geschnitten hat, fand ich genial. Und der Sound ist echt fantastisch, also wirklich mit den richtigen
Kopfhörern. Aber das sind so die Floskeln, man kriegt es hin,
dass man... Aber ich hasse diese Floskeln.
Ich kann mich doch... Ah, das ist
wirklich so, denn
bei Filmfights machen wir
ja manchmal, machen wir ja manchmal
und du warst ja auch schon ein paar Mal dabei
und dann gibt es dann immer Kommentare
und da gibt es dann auch so, letztens hatten wir
der überschätzteste Film und dann war auch so, ja, der Film ist total überschätzt vor allem wegen dem Schnitt und ich dachte halt die Fresse als ob du jetzt genau sagen könntest weil der nicht richtig geschnitten ist ist der Film überschätzt und der Schnitt ist nicht ideal so ein Bullshit das ist das ist ja hier Flosken Interar. Überschätzt? Das ist überhaupt nicht überschätzt. I rest my case. Genau deswegen ist er überschätzt, weil Leute so reagieren. Aber ich will jetzt nicht, dass ich dich provoziere und dann schlägst du mich zusammen wie dein Elektrikerfreund. Pass mal bloß auf, was du da sagst die ganze Zeit. Ja, so hat es wahrscheinlich angefangen. Überschätzt. Pulp Fiction wäre meine Antwort gewesen. Oh, warum? Schnitt. Ja, der Schnitt ist nichts, oder? Dass der dann plötzlich woanders ist? Ja, ja, finde ich doof. Ich habe gestern Pulp Fiction, äh, ich habe gestern, sorry, Fußball geguckt, wollte ich sagen. Aber mein Kopf war noch ganz woanders. Danke, Kopf. Ich habe noch mal Pulp Fiction nachher. Aber ich habe gestern Fußball geschaut, mal wieder, und es sind jetzt die Geisterspiele. Und ich bin nebenbei noch in meiner Unigruppe, wo ich mit sehr vielen Sportjournalisten auch immer noch drin bin, die dann immer fleissig argumentieren und über Fußball reden. Und ich weiß immer nicht, wie viel man über Fußball reden kann, aber anscheinend kann man nächtelang schreiben, die immer. Keine Gruppe erzeugt so viele Nachrichten wie diese Fußballgruppe. Und da ist der Konsens, brecht ab, niemand begeistert Spiele, das ist doch alles scheiße und der Sport lebt ja auch in den Zuschauern. Aber ganz im Ernst, die wievielte Bundesligasaison ist das jetzt? Und es passiert immer das Gleiche und Sportberichterstattung ist somit das Redundanteste, was es gibt auf der Welt. Die Floskeln sind das Redundanteste, es wird immer die gleichen Sachen gesagt. Also das ist die Bullshit-Bingo, einfachste Form eines Bullshit-Bingos, weil du kannst ja einfach, das kennen ja alle, wenn du Sachen aufschreibst, was zum Bingo fällt, Dinge, die häufig gesagt werden. Und es ist nirgendwo so einfach möglich wie beim Fußball, weil da immer die gleichen Sätze fallen an irgendeinem Punkt. Weil natürlich wird das einfach breit getreten, dass am Ende einfach 22 Männer gegeneinander anlaufen und den Ball ins Tor schießen. Das ist ja immer das Gleiche. Und das ist wahnsinnig überschätzt. Fußball ist ein überschätzendes Sportler. Gut, das war die Antwort von Stefan Dietzer, war jetzt nicht die Frage, aber wir kommen zu Antje. Und deswegen ist es doch eigentlich das Beste, was im Sport passieren kann, in den Journalisten, dass endlich mal was anders ist. Weil die Regeln kannst du ja nicht ändern. Weil wenn wir jetzt, angenommen, du spielst mit Freunden irgendwie jeden Abend das gleiche Spiel, irgendwann würdest du doch anfangen, die Regeln zu ändern. Wie es allzu keine Spiele, Werwolf. Irgendwann erfindest du neue Rollen, weil das doch albern ist. Und irgendwann ist es doch total geil, weil die Regeln beim Fußball kannst du nicht ändern, dass du mal irgendwann sagst, jetzt sind mal die Zuschauer weg. Ja, ich finde es auch toll. Als ich das erste Mal gehört habe, Geisterspiel, dachte ich erst mal, das wäre ein Spiel ohne Zuschauer und ohne Spieler. Ohne Spieler. Wo ich dann erst dachte, okay, das ist spannend. Aber ich finde es so geil, dass es bei selbstverständlich beim Deutschen, wo es so ganz präzise Begriffe für alles gibt, dass es nicht irgendwie Abwesenheitsspiel heißt, sondern Geisterspiel.
Das hat sowas so, uh, wir spielen Nacht, so, uh, wir haben ein Bettlaken um, Geisterspiel. Und die Szene, die ich gerne sehen würde, ist, dass jemand so Freistoss oder so richtig hart am Tor vorbeischiesst, Ball fliegt ins Publikum, da aber niemand im Publikum sitzt und den Ball zurückwerfen kann, muss dann einer sich sofort wirklich Kilometer entfernt durch die ganzen Ränge arbeiten, so wie so eine Krebs, so seitlich durchlaufen und alle müssen warten und die Kamera ist so auf dem, der so ganz langsam die Stühle entlang gibt, bis der den Ball hat und wieder reinwerfen kann. Und dann aber auch nicht weit genug wirft. Und dann wieder vorne und dann, oh, und die Spieler setzen sich so hin auf die Wiese und alle müssen warten. Und fangen so an, so rumzureden. Ja, aber das ist doch total geil, weil endlich mal was passiert. Ja. Und es ist ja sogar statistisch belegbar, dass es anders ist. Es finden weniger Sprints statt, es ist auch darauf zurückzuführen, vielleicht, dass die Spieler so ein bisschen aus dem Rhythmus sind und nicht so viel trainieren konnten, aber es wird weniger gesprint, es gibt weniger schnelle Sprints, es fallen mehr Tore. Es ist einfach, es ist total interessant statistisch. Ja, kaum noch Flitzer. Es ist viel weniger Fouls. Ja, keine Hotdogs. Keine Hotdogs. Die haben Hunger. Die schwedigen Hotdogs, barely any Hotdogs. Es ist schwierig, aber ja. Aber gibt es dann eigentlich auch so, gibt es dann jemanden Soundboard, der dann irgendwie so, wenn ein Tor geschossen wird, macht der so Wuh, Wuh. Also Dosenlacher, wie so in den Sitcoms. Ja, genau. So Dosenlacher, das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Yeah. Das ist ein ganz hartes Schnitt. Du hast halt immer den einen drin, der bei jedem Dosenlach immer der seine. Ich glaube, das ist eine Frau, die dann irgendwie so Au macht. Über jeder Sitcom hast du immer diese Lacher. Und die Kommentatoren sitzen auch zu Hause vorm Fernseher. Ja, da können die nicht im Publikum sitzen alleine. Das finde ich immer so unprofessionell, weil die kommentieren dann so wie Väter, die einem sitzen, weil das ja nichts unterscheidet die ja noch, also der ist nicht im Stadion und erlebt es hautnah, nein, der ist auch vom Fernseher und sagt zwischendurch, so schau, kannst du mir mal ein Bier bringen. Ja, alle zehn Minuten hört man so Bierdose zischen, einfach so. Also, ich wünsche euch viel Spaß bei dem nächsten Geisterspielen in der Bundesliga. Gruselt euch nicht vor den Geisterspielen. Wir sitzen nächste Woche wieder hier und erzählen euch ein bisschen was. Gruselt euch nicht vor den Geisterspielen. Wir sitzen
nächste Woche wieder hier und
erzählen euch ein bisschen was. Gruselt euch nicht.
Lasst euch nicht erschrecken.
Lasst euch nicht den kalten Schauer
über den Rücken jagen. Genießt das Wetter,
geht mal raus, geht dann wieder rein,
geht dann wieder rein, weil es draußen zu kalt
oder zu warm oder in jedem Fall nicht
so ist, wie ihr es gerne hättet.
Zu wenig Sitzplätze, zu viele Sitzplätze, zu viele Leute, zu wenig Leute.
Zu viele Slacklines im Weg, man kommt nicht durch den Park.
Zu viele Pollen, zu wenig Pollen.
Man niest, niest das Eis, lässt das Eis fallen.
Drinnen ist so, wie ihr es wolltet.
Eis voller Gras, Graseis, so, das ist dann alles nervig.
Macht's gut, haut rein, schöne Woche, bis dann.
Macht's gut, tschau, wem ab!